la saison 2019-2020 s'annonce riche en
sport dans les yvelines voici notre top
3 des rendez vous qu'il ne faut pas
manquer la saison reprendra par l'un des
événements majeurs du golf français
l'open de france cette 103e édition sera
une nouvelle fois organisé sur le
parcours de l'albatros au golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines
petite particularité cette année
l'événement qui se déroulait fin juin
était déplacé l'automne par l'european
tour du 17 20 octobre les meilleurs
joueurs européens participeront à cette
compétition créée en 1906 pour l'instant
aucune star mondiale n'a confirmé sa
participation
il y aura également du cyclisme dans les
yvelines la saison prochaine la course
au soleil bahrini sera organisée une
nouvelle fois dans le département pour
la onzième année consécutive le peloton
s'élancera depuis une ville yvelinoise
au mois de mars après saint germain en
laye en 2019 et chatou en 2018 quelle
ville organisera la première étape de ce
rendez vous la réponse sera donnée au
plus tard en janvier 2020 l'année
dernière le hollandais dylan gros navet
guen s'est imposé dans la dernière ligne
droite
[Musique]
enfin à la rentrée les amateurs de
course à pied vont se donner rendez vous
ce dimanche 29 septembre à 10 heures
pour la 42e édition du paris versailles
cette année près de 25 mille coureurs
vont une nouvelle fois s'élancer depuis
la tour eiffel pour arriver devant le
château de versailles en passant par la
redoutable côte des gardes à meudon
au total 16 km sont au programme si vous
voulez participer la liste des
inscriptions est ouverte